pendant des années ils ont entraîné des
militaires ukrainien dans leur propre
pays
l'invasion russe à la fin février a
forcé l'interruption de la mission
canadienne
aujourd'hui j'annonce que nous tenons
notre promesse de reprendre l'opération
dans les prochaines semaines la
formation par des soldats canadiens
reprendra pour quatre mois mais cette
fois ci au royaume uni un pays qui
entraîne déjà des militaires eux
craignaient cet échange de connaissances
entre nos deux forces militaires a
nettement amélioré les choses sur le
terrain
mais alors que le gouvernement trudeau
réitère son soutien indéfectible envers
l'ukraine sa loyauté envers le pays est
remise en doute
comme le gouvernement zelensky le
congrès dès ukrainiens canadienne ne
comprend toujours pas pourquoi le canada
à contourner ses propres sanctions est
renvoyé en allemagne une turbine qui
devait permettre au pays de recevoir du
gaz naturel russe à
l'ukraine est encore un allié du canada
demande des conservateurs d'autant que
le renvoi de la turbine marié changer
pour l'instant le gazoduc north stream 1
qui relie la russie à l'allemagne ne
fonctionne toujours pas à pleine
capacité
pourquoi est-ce qu'on continuerait de se
plier au chantage de moscou en
acheminant d'autres turbine demande le
npd le ministre wilkinson rappelle que
le canada des obligations envers ses
alliés européens encore très dépendants
du gaz russe ont
des contraintes bien réelle pour les
européens qui force le canada a passé
outre ses engagements quitte à décevoir
les ukrainiens c'est donc un nouveau jeu
d'équilibriste pour le gouvernement
trudeau qu'il expose encore une fois à
la critique ici leur enceinte et radio
canada ottawa